και να δούμε τι συμπεδι πάρα πολύκο τις μας πέρουμε το παιδί του και δεν
υπήρχε δήποτε δεν υπάρχει δώ αυτή είναι δουλειά μας αυτό προσπαθούμε α εξυπηρορήζοε τον κόσμο
αλλά να μιλούμε νανα ξέρουμε τι μαι γίνεται και να τους παροτρίδονε τα παιδιά να
σχολούνται και κάτι άλλο δικτώ πγονείς εμπιστεύονται πλέον και να κλαίσουμε με αυτό ικ είς
εμπιστεύονται πλέο τις αρχές ώστε ο αστυνομικός να μάθει για κάτι τόσο εβαίσειτο που αφορά
το σπίτι το επιστεύοτ ναι παλιά επιτή υπήρχει ο τροοποία να μην πούμε κμικρή κοινωνία
ο πλέον ιγονείς μιλούή εμπιστευτικότητα προπάνοντο για το ηλεκτρονικόν έμπλεμααλλά και τισε άλλες περικές καλές
υπηρεσιες η εμπιστευτικότητα είναι στο ύψεις των που υπάρχει σε καμία επερίπτωση δεν πρόκετει να
και προκαλώ οποιο δποτε να διημουσιοποιηθεί ή να εκθέσιουμε τοπιο δήποτε ποεπαιδί υπάρχουν υπάρχει ο
υπάρα πολύ καλή αντααποκρισ απτοκοινώ πιστεύω ότι τοκοινώ μας εμπιστεύεται και καλό του γοτης να
συνεχίζουν ο πράτουν είμαστε ικί για να τους εξυκηρετούμε υτό πληρωνόύμα αστήν αυτό είναι η
δουλειά μας ξεκατί ότι δήποτε αντιμετωπίζουν και ποιο τι ήπτε άλληενέργεια σευτον κόσμο του ηλεκτροντικού
εγκλήματος είμαστε και χαριστό πολύ αυτή η συζήση και όσαντιαναφερόντα μας επες γύρω απότε από
το πλούσιον έργο που έχει μπροστά το το ελεκτομικόν έγκλημα και τις προκλήσεις οι οποίες
είναι καθημερινές το χαριστό πολε και εγώ ευχαριστούαστε καλάκαι λες και φίιάλνατααλάποτκα ευτάσι το τέλος
το τα λέμε την ερχόμενα πλοματ